Your God is a tat. Why? Because you
worship him. You do as he says. You
don't do what he tells you not to do.
You do what he tells you to do. To you,
that's your Allah.
Do not forget to check out cindi.com.
from brothers and sisters, one of my
most amazing clothing brands that I
wear, alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims
with the recent boycott that's going on
with many brands, clothing lines
supporting Israel. Brothers and sisters,
you guys know I've been supporting
Sydney.com. I've been wearing their
stuff long, long time ago.
Alhamdulillah. And I love their
clothing, brothers and sisters. It's
exactly what I like. Alhamdulillah, when
it comes to fitness, training, jogging,
just general wear when I'm praying. I
don't need to worry about my back
showing. Buy it for your family members,
your your uncles, your brothers, your
husbands, whoever it is. Inshallah, bro,
sisters, buy it for yourself inshallah.
It's modest clothing wear
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well inshallah. So
this is a video that's been circulating
that was sent to me uh well that would
send it to me and also brother Mhhammed
sent it to me and it's a bit disturbing
but also you guys might know Turkey.
Turkey is nearly 50/50 50% secular 50%
alhamdulillah practicing Muslims and
tensions are always been there etc going
back and forward 10 20 years ago even 30
years ago Muslim women could not wear
the hijab in certain places stateowned
schools courtrooms etc. They had to take
the hijabs off. They couldn't graduate.
And subhan Allah, with the new uh
leadership, alhamdulillah, that's gotten
much much better. Muslims have a right,
alhamdulillah, woman, to wear the hijab
and practice their religion. So, there
is this divide uh between them.
Alhamdulillah. But sadly, there's this
video circulating of absolute mockery of
the prayer. So, these are from
secularist uh those who worship. Yeah.
Someone um who's come to change the adan
to Turkish um and subhan Allah, somebody
who's you know, just hates Islam in a
nutshell. Let's be honest with that
matter when you look at the history of
Islam it's the Ottoman rule with all due
respect if there's anything it's very
ironic it's the Ottoman rule that took
over Constantinople alhamdulillah if
anything they don't realize that it is
their ancestors their great-grandfathers
if they want to be proud of something
it's not nationalism it's not with your
respect it is the Ottoman Empire yes
let's be honest here's a video let's go
to the video inshallah watch for ourself
it's disgusting but again the only
excuse I can make is just young childish
children who look at this and be ashamed
of theirel here's a video let's go to in
to ourel and See what we can learn out
of this.
So Allah says in the Quran, "The
hypocrites fear that a surah should be
revealed about them, exposing what is in
their hearts." Say, "Oh prophet, keep
mocking. Allah will definitely bring to
light what you fear." If you question
them, they will certainly say, "We were
only taking talking idly and joking
around." Say, "Was it Allah, his
revelations, and his messenger that you
ridiculed?" Make no excuses. You have
lost faith after you believe. If we
pardon a group of you, we will punish
others for their wickedness. The
hypocrites, both men and women, are all
alike. They encourage what is evil,
forbid what is good, and withhold what
is in their hands. They neglected Allah,
so he neglected them. Surely the
hypocrites are the rebellious. So here
the verse, subhan Allah, like you think
you're just mocking Allahh. Allah says
they neglected Allah, so Allah neglected
them. So those who forget Allah like
Allah says in the Quran as well those
who forgive remembers this Allah will
make them forget their own self. It's
only that they forgive they don't
remember Allah that they behave in this
manner because anyone that understood
who Allah subhana wa tala is will not be
doing these actions. So you can see that
Allah has uh they've forgotten Allah.
They've done that and Allah in return
has made them forget their own self.
Like look at the way they're behaving.
Smoking, pretending or mocking the death
of someone in prayer. And you can see
these are young kids. Stupidity uh at
its highest. And I'm sure they are
regretful. Even if they're not regretful
in this day, they're going to be
regretful on the day of judgment.
[clears throat] And subhuman sisters, it
just shows us and they are mocking. They
are laughing like the exactly what they
did. If you look at surah mutaf towards
the end of the verse, Allahh tells us
that the believers will be on reclining
sofas and they will be laughing. We are
going to be laughing back at them on
that day. And I'm not seeing these
individuals cuz we don't know where
they're going to end up. They could be
better people than us then they repent.
But Allah says on that day the believers
will be on reclining sofas and we will
be laughing at them. The the way they
used to mock us, oh you wear the hijab,
you do this, you do that, etc. And Allah
says they will look at them and see if
the disbelievers have been paid for what
they used to do. which shows Allahh's
justice on that day. On the day of
judgment, it's going to be a graduation
day. That's what I call it. I call it a
graduation day. A graduation day for the
believers. And if you look at these
secularists, these people who worship
with all due respect, they worship a man
who's dead. His bodies are decayed. Yes.
And that's what they're doing. And then
they think that they are free. This is
the funny part. They actually think that
they are free. They say, "Oh, we don't
believe in God and we don't believe in
this stuff." Your God is at with all due
respect. Your God is at Why? because you
worship him. You do as he says. You
don't do what he tells you not to do.
You do what he tells you to do. To you,
that's your Allah with all due respect.
And guess what? He's a man that's dead.
Yes. So if you think about it, you come
and say, you know, all these secularists
come and say, "Oh, I'm free. I don't
follow religion." Really, is it? If
that's the case, then why do you guys
all dress up the same? Why do you all
dress up the same? Why do you all do the
same things? If you are so free, this is
a a pattern. Yes. This is this is a a a
a cycle, a pattern that you do. Yes.
You're against religious people. Yeah.
That's your religion. Your religion is
to be against religious people. Okay.
That's your way of life. You dress up
how you like apparently. No, you don't.
Cuz the fashion tells you what to do.
Yes. Botox. Yes. Come on. Like with all
respect, I have family members. Yes. A
lot of them. Yes. Female family members.
All of them. Wa. I'll be honest with
you. They are so unhappy with the way
they look. They make theel look more
terrible. With those due respect. Yes.
Getting this done, getting that done.
Why? because they are worshiping
theirel. I ask Allah's guidance for
them. But I'm just saying it's a
reality. I'm involved in this community.
They are part of my community. I'm
Kurdish from Turkey. And this is what we
see. They are a slave to society. Yes.
What others think of them. When they
come to their house, this they're in
competition. Look how good my house
looks. Oh, I got this curtains from
Turkey. Handmade. I spent £3,000. Why?
Because they're in competition with one
another. They worship one another. Oh,
what car do you drive? Oh, what land of
property do you own in Turkey? Oh, yeah.
I got these cups. Look, they got this
gold thing. One of the reasons I came to
Islam is because of this. The absolute
humiliation,
the absolute servitude and slave, being
a slave to other human beings. How can I
prove myself to them? Oh, I need to
drive this car, have a degree for that.
You are so busy and occupied that you
are a slave to all of these people and
you are in the debts of unhappiness.
That's the reality. And Islam has come
to break those invisible shackles and
tell you do not worship any man or woman
and worship the true creator. So the
thing that you are mocking on the day of
judgment, you are going to hit your
face. Yes, you are going to hit your
face and be like what a loss. When your
deed when your book is given to you on
your left hand or behind you and Allah
says in the Quran, they will say woe
unto me. And when they open their book,
they will say, "What kind of a book is
this that it hasn't missed anything
small or big?" That means that that book
is going to be in such detail that they
are going to be in utter shock that
they're going to say, "Wow, it's even
recorded that one little sin that I
done." They are going to be in absolute
shock to be like, "Wow, this is a clear
day of judgment." And the wrongdoers,
those who earned hellfire, they had to
earn it. And those who were given
paradise, they were gifted with it. So
don't blame no one that day. And the
disbelievers on that day in the hellfire
would say, "Oh my Lord, give us one more
chance." Do you know why they're going
to say, "Give us one more chance." And
not say, "Oh Allah, you have wronged
us." Cuz they're going to know exactly
why they're in hellfire. And that day,
it's over. No more chances. Because
Allah says it's only a word that you
say. Cuz if they were sent back to this
earth, they would do the same thing
again like a repeat offender. That's why
they'll be in the hellfire forever. May
Allah guide these people. That's what
I'm going to say inalamlaykum.